what do you want people to know kind of
and miss him
George Floyd's six year old daughter
Gianna has a message for the world what
was your dad like he playing with me she
didn't have to play with nobody else
because daddy was gonna play one all day
long yeah I mean that was his baby
he loved his little girl Gianna and her
mother Roxy Washington sat down with
Good Morning America how did you explain
what happened to your daughter
but Gianna knew something was wrong she
doesn't know what happened I told her
there her dad back cuz Gianna may not
know exactly what happened to her father
but she does know everyone is talking
about her dad she's seen here in this
video with one of George Floyd's closest
friends NBA veteran Steven James on
Wednesday Gianna attended her father's
memorial the service was live-streamed
and featured a number of tributes and
rallying cries in George's memory George
Floyd should not be among the deceased
including from George's brother a
felonious Floyd we come up together we
didn't have much I mom did what she
could my brother we did a lot of things
together from like talking with my mom
dancing with my mom cooking with our mom
brothers and sisters so much you know
I'm just staying strong as I can because
I need to get it out I need to get it
out everybody wants justice we want
justice for George he's gonna get it
he's gonna get it
[Applause]